aux etats unis des divisions au sein du
parti républicain des sanctions ont été
prises contre deux élus pour leur
participation à la commission d' enquête
parlementaire sur les violences du 6
janvier 2021 au capitole une manoeuvre
qui a provoqué de vives réactions au
sein du parti qui se déchire
publiquement sur cette question à
quelques mois des élections de mi mandat
elle les détails de notre correspondant
à washington tom abonnés
c'est une expression ou plus exactement
trois mots qui sont à l'origine de cette
fracture interne au sein du parti
républicain en fin de semaine dernière
le comité national du parti décide de
sanctionner deux de ses membres pour
leur participation à la commission d'
enquête parlementaire chargée des
événements du 6 janvier 2021 au capitole
pour justifier sa décision le parti
publie un texte on peut lire que ces
deux parlementaires participent je cite
à une persécution menée par les
démocrates contre des citoyens
ordinaires engagé dans une expression
politique légitime ces trois derniers
mots expressions politiques légitimes
pour qualifier les événements du 6
janvier a provoqué de vives critiques au
sein du parti certains prennent leur
distance à commencer par mitch mcconnell
le leader républicain au sein du sénat
et coûter
il s'agissait d'une insurrection
violente dont le but d'essayer
d'empêcher le transfert pacifique du
pouvoir d'une administration à l'autre
après une élection légitimement
certifier c'est de ça dont il s'agit
c'est en ce qui concerne la suggestion
selon laquelle le congrès du parti
devrait être chargé de choisir les
républicains qu'il convient de soutenir
le point de vue traditionnel des comités
nationaux des partis et que nous
soutenons tous les membres de notre
parti quelle que soit leur position sur
certaines questions
et depuis on assiste à une série de
commentaires de la part des élus
républicains certains défendant cette
formule employée sur le 6 janvier
d'autres assumant volontiers une
divergence avec l'ancien président
donald trump qui n'a évidemment pas
manqué de réagir à cette polémique
attend lui aussi une prise de distance
avec mitch mcconnell écouter mitch
mcconnell ne parle pas pour le parti
républicain et ils ne représentent pas
la vision d'une vaste majorité de ses
électeurs
il n'a rien fait pour se battre pour ses
concitoyens et pour arrêter l'élection
la plus frauduleux de l'histoire
américaine
cette affaire illustre les divergences
d'opinions au sein du parti républicain
que ce soit sur la journée du 6 janvier
mais plus généralement sur donald trump
l'ancien président semble toujours
bénéficié d'un soutien d'une large base
électorale mais de nombreuses
personnalités au sein de son parti ont
décidé de prendre leurs distances
notamment sur ses accusations répétées
sur une éventuelle fraude électorale
alors ces guerres intestines
interviennent à quelques mois maintenant
des élections de mi mandat au cours
desquels elle les républicains comptent
récupérer une majorité au congrès